hi guys it's silver at again with
another episode of this tutorial series
now as you might notice I actually made
this path over here a little bit more
straight and this is because obviously
it's a sloped path and adding curves the
sloped paths is something that's really
a fighter pool you really have to get
the right sets and you can do it it's
it's very much possible but it's really
hard especially if you have real curves
that really change the direction of the
plot so in this case I kind of made it
more straight and I'm gonna add borders
and fences right now so now the center
aisle I always like to use for this is
CTOs paths too because it does have the
curves that go along with the shyguys
planters and many other paths sets
curves but it's also conforming and i
just really love the texture and the
look of this thing so that's why i'm
using this right here now as you might
see you have various pieces in this set
like you have the high pieces and the
low pieces now this should technically
qu'ran match up like that but you
shouldn't be too afraid of that since
for example I only have a more diagonal
over here so I can't actually connect
and the two curves here but that's
nothing to really worry about plus if
you don't say it people will most likely
not actually notice it in the video it's
just because I just said it which was
kind of a mistake on my part should have
said it you wouldn't probably have
noticed it but anyway um so I'm just
gonna do this on the borders of this
path and as you can see by way here is a
three tile wide curve now as you might
tell from the set there are no three
titled white curves in this set so I'm
gonna have to use another piece of the
set and in walls there are other pieces
of this set they're not conforming but
it does include the curves like a curve
that I need to use over there so don't
worry about that
now I'm just going to finish all of this
use these diagonals let's see does that
match up no it does not so I'm just
gonna use these horse and that looks
pretty good now I'm just gonna finish
this as well
and remember if you have horth pieces
like this you can always just add a
whole piece yeah - to make sure that it
all connects nicely the curved pieces
have a high end on both sides so that's
something that you might want to
remember so as you can see they're still
like gap left but I'm gonna do that
later on because I don't want to quite
close this set yet because that's gonna
cost me some time now as you can see as
I built these curbs along the edge of
the path you can see that they will
conform to the terrain and as long as
you add conforming railings or fences as
well you won't have any problems making
conforming pots and like I said
conforming pots are often quite a hassle
to work with but they do look they do
work really nicely in the end okay so
that looks good now it does look like I
need to bring it out more over there if
I went to informant to connect it to
that path so that's like walk over there
so I'm just gonna add a north piece over
here and as you can see even the
straight two diagonal curved pieces
conform to the terrain so that's really
great now okay I messed up on that one I
don't think I really care about that
never mind okay I do want to get these
diagonals light though what you can also
do is just place them like this I am one
direction and then just rotate it and
place the other ones like that also you
see to rotate like I just did I am just
just the stupid idiot I never got used
to that I still don't want to use seed
to rotate but um everyone tells me which
is true it's much easier to do that so
don't be like me don't be stupid
don't get used to a different way of
things and just practice with Z it will
probably make your life ten times better
okay now I'm just gonna add this curve
that looks beautiful really like that
way this looks with it is it's more of a
rustic kind of texture and set but it
does work in this case I guess
okay now I'm just going to open the
conforming pot part of the sack again
because I don't really need any more big
curves I think oh wait there is this
curve though that I I don't know about
that I don't think it's too bad though
just gonna keep it over there okay so
I'm just gonna this part again I'm also
gonna do the fences in this episode I
know that this series is really dragging
on right now see that the the thing that
I had in mind for the series is just
record me building a coaster not per se
a tutorial in a way that most people do
tutorials the text and stuff like that
just me making a coaster and try to
explain things and explain my thought
process along the way but now that I do
realize yeah it does take a lot of time
to make a coaster so it yeah it does go
it does turn out to be a very long
series I'm probably the layouts part of
this is probably still the best part of
the tutorial series since it's not as
boring I guess but anyway I'm just gonna
finish this real quick and also I do
have plans to make a similar kind of
tutorial video or a series which is
smaller and probably time lapsed as well
that's or I can make a huge time-lapse
of this series just turn it into one big
time-lapse and upload that I might also
do that since I have recorded everything
so that would be pretty cool so yeah I
do admit this is kind of some boring
work it's really hard to give tips when
you've already kind of set everything
about it that's the that's the problem
with path works in general okay but I do
like this I do need to remember to hook
this up to the rocks over there so I'm
just going to do that right now okay and
there are many many fence sets now this
is something I always see many people
using the same sets over and over again
there is no need to do that I'll just
give away some of my favorites I really
like shy guys planters it's a it's a
somewhat overused sack but it's still
great but so
sets that I kind of recently got into
our branch of Spencer's are of course
give a download link in the description
and I feel like I want to try one of
these Spencer's over here now the
question is I really like that with the
wooden fence but question is whether I
can actually use it since this is a
generic coaster so it wouldn't really
fit the theme so I might in the end mash
is also climbing rustic so I think I'm
gonna go with ornamental in this case
okay now I'm in there and I'm in the
foliage bytes by the way many fence sets
have can have their conforming pieces in
the foliage parts and war pieces in
their wall spots that's just something
to remember it makes it a lot easier if
you know that to kind of loop into it
sets yeah now this is also one of the
reasons why I like to keep my sloped
path yeah sections straight since many
pet fencing fence sets don't have
conforming curved pieces like this okay
now this this looks pretty decent the
colors aren't great though um let's see
I mean I could do a very bright color
but then again that wouldn't make too
much sense as a sense as a fence that's
a stupid sentence gray is not really too
nice either
perhaps white work out this is always
just some trial and error definitely
something that you need to get done but
yeah white is not really doing it for me
either
just maybe red but that's - Rhett
perhaps I could try brown balls and a
red top thing you know what I actually
like that I think hmm I want to go with
them that has the question is it good
enough I don't think it's really good
enough talk really out there you know
what I'm just gonna I'm actually just
gonna try the wooden fences onion
carrots this is a generic coaster and
wood doesn't really fit the theme I'm
just gonna try it
I think this looks good enough I'm just
gonna go with this always and I can't
stress this you know always before you
actually do the fences and other curves
stuff like that always test all of the
sets that you have and make sure that
you really like this act that you're
using because once you've placed many of
these fences you don't want to go back
you don't want to go out there and
remove all of the fences again because
that's a lot of work and that's a lot of
waste of time to always make sure that
you really want to use some once at and
before you actually start working with
it okay that looks pretty good
now I do need to remember that for this
point I need to use the conforming part
of the set also as you might notice with
this set and many other sets you don't
actually have the pause with many of the
pieces you need to place the poles
yourself so and yeah this does make it
hard to build fences with it since it
takes more time but then again I also
like it since it does make a set more
flexible you can always use the ports
for other things you can place as many
pauses you like for example I mm-hmm I
most often just use poles and every
square but you can also use them every
other square or twice and two poles on a
square and yeah after this I kind of
need to use the conforming pop yeah
piece as well so I can't really do that
yet and the poles in this set I caught
the plugs so if you if you need to place
those things always look for the plates
and plug number-10 always just works for
the normal placements oops I just missed
one over there definitely when to place
that before I forget it okay and
actually know especially with this set
make sure that the plugs are actually on
the full tile placement because
otherwise you won't leave those ugly
empty gaps with many sets it won't
really won't make a difference like
station Jim's fencing but for this
particular set always make sure that you
place the plugs on the full tile
okay now I'm just gonna open the
conforming part of the set conforming
part of the sex toy now as you can see
this does have the porcine so you don't
have to worry about non conforming poles
and stuff like that now I do see that
this is not really doing what I want it
to do and both pieces with that Ashley
okay hot piece of work
nevermind just I'm just gonna use that
mop pieces then okay now I think that
this curve is straight already so that
should be okay but before I forget that
I need to go to this bite and at them
over here now I'm not really too happy
about how this turned out especially
since loose use the off style placements
and my own balls use the full tile
placement but yeah that's something that
I'll just have to do with I guess now
I'm just gonna quickly finish these
fences just gonna open the wall support
again come on mate oh yeah path work
really takes a lot of time I don't like
doing pot work to be fair and well the
thing with path work is the fact that
it's not really that creative it's not
really that much input like creativity
the thing with it is that it's just so
simple it's just the same thing all over
and over again and it gets boring after
a while and it's it's not as fun to me
as building goings for example so yeah I
myself don't even really like doing it
it's just something that you have to get
done you can't get around you so okay so
I'm just gonna use control to keep it at
the same height because as you can see
the conforming I mean the non-conforming
pieces kind of do weird stuff when
there's a very slight slope so I always
use control to keep them at the same
height
now it does look like yeah I do need a
pole over there
okay that's good I'm just gonna add the
poles in advance here and now that I've
got those balls anyway now this group is
gonna be a problem now that I think of
it since it is a poor curve and I will
need to find a fence for it so that's
gonna be that's actually gonna be a
problem that I did not think of before
you know what I'm just not gonna an
offense over there okay
and I think that's too much of a problem
since you've already got those high
curbs and I can actually turn this into
a garden kind of thing yeah I'm actually
going to do that so that'll be it for
today's episode hope you enjoyed and
learned something and on to the next
episode in which I actually do want to
get to doing some foliage so see you
then